sans 1,3 milliard de dollars c'est le
chiffre d'affaires que devrait générer
fire l'année prochaine selon les
estimations de svb leewin qu un chiffre
d'affaires qui a doublé en quatre ans un
peu moins de 30 milliards proviendraient
du vaccin contre le coc vide et plus de
24 milliards de la pilule anti qu'ovide
face aux variants omicron la commission
européenne a annoncé de nouvelles
livraisons du sérum de l'américain au
premier trimestre de 2022 bwin take five
year livre aura 20 millions de doses de
vaccins supplémentaires 5 millions en
janvier 5 millions en février et 10
millions en mars ces doses viennent
s'ajouter aux 195 millions de doses déjà
prévu par bixente kraiser ce qui porte
le nombre total de livraisons au premier
trimestre à 215 millions il faut dire
que le vaccin du laboratoire pfizer a le
vent en poupe
déjà en mars dernier il était celui qui
inspirait le plus confiance aux français
52% d'entre eux déclaraient alors avoir
confiance en faveur contre 43% en
moderna et 20% en astrazeneca la
tendance est la même aujourd'hui comme
le rapporte libération le vaccin father
reste plébiscité dans certains centres
de vaccination
pourtant olivier verrons a insisté début
décembre sur le régal potentiel
j'insiste moderne iphise heures c'est
pareil la seule différence c'est que si
vous avez moins de 30 ans on préfère
vous donnez du finder et ce n'est pas
pour des raisons d'efficacité
comment expliquer cette préférence
communication habitudes plusieurs
facteurs sont à prendre en compte comme
explique que cette sociologue au
washington post plusieurs marques de
vaccins sont sortis et files heures et
celle qui a été le plus plébiscité par
les médias mais pas seulement la
communication autour de ce vaccin n'a
pas souffert d'autant de bad buzz que
les autres ces personnes ont déjà eu une
ou deux doses de pfizer elles savent à
quoi s'attendre comme le dit très bien
l'adage on sait ce qu'on perd pas ce
qu'on retrouve l'expérience personnelle
d'un vaccin ou celle de ses proches tout
cela en facilite l'acceptation files
heures pourrait bien mettre ko ses
concurrents sur le front du coc vide
notamment avec ça nous elle pilule pack
solide qui vient d'être autorisé par le
gouvernement américain de son côté
l'agencé européenne du médicament
approuvé son utilisation dans un
contexte d'utilisation d'urgence